it was risky we didn't see the Land
There were so many things that could
have gone wrong
you're already in property you bought a
house which didn't go super well you had
a rent to rent that you didn't realize
was a red Duran for us to be able to go
from some 50 60 hours a week to a 15
hour a week no one gives that kind of
value for free huge amount of profit
from properties that you don't own
technically our first property was by
accident we're gonna do with this big
old house that we got now that we are on
the academy we know the steps of how to
do this and protect yourself how much
profit are you making from those lunch
events yeah I would say maybe be
well welcome to winners on a Wednesday
and massive congratulations for all your
huge success thank you and quitting your
job and everything as well talk to me
about what has been your main strategy
over the last year or so and how have
you managed to reach Financial Freedom
been to Vance video so for anyone
watching this the
understand what rent to rent is or if
they think rent to rent is risky what is
it how does rent to rent work
so rent to rent I would say in simple
terms will be
the ability for someone to rent a
property off of a owner for a set price
and then let that property using
different strategies so it could be um
short stay like a service accommodation
or it could be a multiple LED with hmos
and how many properties of you now got
control of using redirect strategy how
many keys have you got we got 14 14
yes is it stressful at times yeah you're
still working full-time yes and you've
now quit I quit yeah yeah you're working
as a plumber yeah how much time would
you say a week you have to spend
managing your 14 units yeah I would say
maybe 15 hours okay for us yeah so
you're working sort of like part-time on
the property business
how much profit are you making from
those renter rents about seven and a
half Grand seven and a half Grand yeah
high five
so seven half Grand that's a huge salary
um a you know a huge amount of profit
from properties that you don't own
um what would you say is the best tip
you would give somebody because you've
worked hard you've joined the academy
you've put a lot of time and effort into
this that's what you've been successful
um it's not it's not something that can
just happen overnight it's something
that you have to build you've got to set
your company up and you've got to get
the right training you've got to learn
how to speak to landlords how to
actually manage the properties but what
would you say your best piece of advice
to somebody would be that wants to make
seven and a half Grand a month from
properties that they don't own starting
with little money what's your best
advice uh best of us will be uh
education uh educates on your uh you
know field of expectations and uh train
yourself to do the right strategies or
else it's going to be very very
difficult some people want to learn from
experience and they try to learn from
making mistakes but it's good but it
takes a long time so yeah it's not
necessary to be making mistakes you just
have to to invest into the appropriate
training follow a strategy that works
and get on it and one of the things that
I would say is not be afraid of long
nights in right now we spend about
15 hours a week working on on our
portfolio but it started with 50 hours a
week we didn't sleep we had to go and do
it we had to listen to a lot of
rejections after rejections but don't be
discouraged I think that's going to be
my main tip and I think you're right as
well about you know don't reinvent the
wheel because if you're speaking to
landlords you're going to get a lot more
rejections if you're just winging it
whereas if you go in actually with a
script and you know what you're saying
it's going to be you'll still get
rejected but it'll be much easier same
with tenants you can't afford to put a
bad tenant in your property you can't
afford to make a big mistake it can
literally bankrupt you so knowing how to
navigate through that I think is really
important talk to me about your first
deal then how did you find it and when
did it happen technically our first
property was by accident so I don't even
want to count this one but this is when
you bought rent to rent we bought our
first property okay and then we had the
rent to rent which was a accident Mentor
because it was meant to be for work
employees and an intend that to be
actually something that I was you know
yeah and we came across one
Okay so
we well so we bought one property
because we went to a bad training that
we're not going to say the names of the
trainers but we went through a back
training we got the wrong advice and we
bought a property that's
cost us a lot of money oh ouch sorry
jealous yeah but don't worry that's fine
it wasn't it wasn't me though no it
wasn't no it wasn't after that we just
continued on with work I do education
and I teach friends to young children so
I have a lot of staff that coming from
France so with brexit that anyway we
just had to have some place so that our
staff can come from abroad and and work
so that's how we came across the first
property that we have now on rent to
rent and we didn't know it wasn't rent
to rent at the time and then we started
listening to YouTube and how to become
financially free and some random videos
and we got your video and it was events
it was a video where you went and stayed
at his yeah I remember that because it
was playing very loud so she made sure
that I watched it yeah yeah because he
had 23 pounds didn't he yeah yeah it was
but it was just so inspirational because
you literally
went and
just changed that guy's life in just
like that and you put yourself on the
line going to a place where you didn't
know where you was even gonna sleep but
you were committed to your task that was
the first video you saw and this is when
we thought oh my God we have a rent to
rent and we didn't know it was so then
we changed the way that we managed it
went on the cash girls books for another
course we went to the other course I
think it was the the brr the first
course that we went first we went to was
in Marble Archer
were you scarred though from the
previous training that you went on with
somebody else or did you just realize it
was different and let it go or how did
that come into it did realize it was
different from the information and you
know it was just different and there
wasn't really a lot of information about
properties sort of basic yeah so yeah it
was to me I mean he is he's really more
easy going than I am I'm an educator so
I'm very methodological and
having that experience with them I
thought you know what we're gonna do
with this big old house that we got but
um he was a bit more calm so I think
that really helped me when we got to
yours well by the time we got to yours
we listened to have probably 100 of your
videos so we were already knowing that
okay this guy is too definitely on
another level
and when we went to the crash course
which by the way was free no one gives
that kind of value for free
so initially there was always a little
bit of skepticism I thought what is he
getting out of it you know we were
already able with your videos to kind of
change our mindset just a little bit on
the whole thing
and then going to crash course for free
we literally had to put just a pound
deposit we just went there and had so
much value that we felt like
how
um and then we booked for another course
on the back of that I think it was the
following month and straight away we we
didn't even finish the course we just
signed up for the academy and again like
the academy as well like there's no Hard
Sell or anything it's just like this is
what the academy is have a chat with
somebody yeah you know this is the
investment this is what you get and now
you've been on the academy for what how
long like 10 months yeah yeah yeah so
you you were already in property you'd
bought a house which didn't go super
well you had a rent to rent that you
didn't realize was a red to Red so you
thought man with some guidance and some
support maybe we can really we can
really do things when was your first
actual proper rent to rent since joining
the academy when you had your eyes open
well it was Bradford Bradford yeah and
it was January so it was just a couple
of months after joining your Academy
that we got our first one but a couple
of months it may seem like a short
amount of time and we feel like you know
but it goes really really long when
you're getting nose after nose after
nose you do hundreds of miles in
traveling Looking Back Now everyone
watches this and goes oh you got a rent
to rent in two months that's fast but at
the time after a month and three weeks
you probably thought is this ever going
to happen yeah but Bradford sounds like
an interesting area like Bradford's
quite a cheap area yeah what is it it's
a very luxurious
um Apartments okay and um it's a new
development isn't it yeah it's a new
developer well it's an old build
10 minutes okay yeah okay like towards
Leeds yes okay good so that's a slightly
nicer part yeah yeah yeah and um it was
just it was amazing it was just um we
had so many diff well we did it a little
bit differently because this one we got
out of a Sousa that's on the academy by
the way so the network again is helping
us we got a couple of bad deals before
that yeah that um thankfully we always
kind of went through the academy before
accepting anything so that deal was the
first one that we thought you know what
this guy is you know really good let's
just have a go with him sure and you met
him on the academy so you knew he was
just there's accountability there
absolutely and on the back of that there
is contacts there is Network there is
you know we got another property in the
same building yeah and it just started
so it's a beautiful luxury apartment in
Bradford and you're renting it for how
much for two grand oh wow and yeah it's
a penthouse okay yeah it's a four beds
well kind of a five bed for we turn one
of the bedroom into an office okay so
it's a four bedroom penthouse and we're
charging an average of 200 to 230 a
night and uh we are on average 21 to 23
nights okay in a month and how much
profit does that want does that one make
you reckon a month on average between
800 and a thousand solid and then you
start getting deals in Coventry yes yeah
well these deals you're finding yourself
or we're using a saucer yeah we're
finding ourselves and then you were
using the Bradford one as a bit of a hey
look we've already got this yeah because
we already had a relationship with our
landlord that we had in London for the
rent to rent that we had by accident
yeah so we already had that as a solid
reference then we we had the Bradford
within the Bradford the networking that
happened is that the building manager
now came to us directly when they had
new Flats in the building and outside
you know for to have so we built that
um sort of ease to speaking and and and
negotiating deals so now it became much
more easier to then go into our patch
which was Coventry initially and finding
those deals and starting to just play
around with the numbers
demos or service accommodation we've got
we've got service accommodation yep
who's staying in these service
accommodations though in Coventry who
wants to go to Coventry for a couple
days
yeah and how much the pain tonight uh so
we've got one that's not too high-end
it's still very cute yeah but it's not
too high-end we got it for 1 300 and
that well yeah that house has an Annex
so the annex is um it's like a detached
Studio okay that is attached to a
property and the studio we're renting it
are for 700 pounds oh wow so solid and
the rest of the house which is a lot
before that we are letting it for 90
pounds on average 80 to 90 pound a night
damn how much profit are you getting
from that from from that one a solid
700. that's beautiful and how much money
did you have to spend refurbing it and
getting it all up to scratch or did you
not spend over a grand but I feel really
and true we could have you know done it
in a cheap but obviously it was an
experience so yeah so you spent about a
grand or so getting it done up and that
makes 700 quid a month and then you got
another one another one did you say
you've got what 14. yeah 14 properties
yeah
incredible yeah and if you bought any
houses no no you almost bought a piece
of land that we stopped you buying cards
thank you this
I could not yeah you know I'm buying
London owls bro I know and that's why
because I saw you you know in one of the
training you said of how much you know
you were explaining not really going
into detail because the training was
about something else but you started
kind of touching up on development and
you shared you know some of your um
current projects and you thought oh my
God that's just down the road from me
some of them didn't go well though yeah
some of them went well but yeah not that
bad because normally when we buy land we
bought on an option yeah and then if we
don't get planning or whatever we just
yeah we've lost 10 grand it's not the
end of the world but you were looking to
actually buy something weren't you yeah
it was risky we didn't see the Land
There was there were so many things that
could have gone wrong that we didn't see
of course but obviously we always took
your advice and said okay you are on the
academy make use of this Powerhouse
between Tony as well didn't you yeah and
Tony's like a guru Tony is the man Tony
literally laid it out for us Well he
kind of made us let it out to him yeah
and the more we started telling him you
know what the deal was the more he he
would just repeat the question he's just
so funny that kind of like Minds Mind
Games yeah you just pulled it apart yeah
so he would repeat what I just said and
I'm gonna oh yeah well when you say it
like that it doesn't really sound really
so and then he just broke it down and
said look you know I'm gonna give him a
nice opinion based on that that that
that I wouldn't touch it the thing is
that Priscilla is yeah being on the
academy is not just about telling you
yeah you can do it you got this and
telling you to go and do it and take
action it's also telling you not to do
certain stuff and every time you're
about to do a deal every time you're
about to sign the dotted lines having
someone that you can just run it past is
really important yes yeah yeah I mean I
mean it was it was disappointed we
thought yeah this is the deal and uh as
soon as he said oh it's not going to
work it was like yeah yeah it will come
though it will come yeah it definitely
helped us because
um even the approach of us doing it
professionally you know when we bought
our first house we didn't go the most
professional way when we had our
entrance it was also something that was
not done in the best of ways it turned
out great because the owner was was
almost awesome but it wasn't the best
now that we are on the academy we know
the steps of how to do this and protect
yourself and of solicitors and paperwork
and contracts and all of these things so
even if the but the deal was bad with
the land because we had gone through
those steps we were already covered we
could pull out as soon as Tony you know
worked out the magic and told us look
it's not really the best thing we were
able to put out very quickly very clean
and with no liability whereas if we were
not educated by your Academy members and
you know paperwork and all of that we
would have had to lose money in it the
reservation all of these things you know
yeah how did you guys meet then how long
have you guys been together we've been
together for
[Laughter]
you had to think about really hard three
children later I imagine what was it the
first marriage you want to get into
property yeah I was just seeing a lot of
things that people were doing on
building sites and uh obviously looking
at our first property we thought yeah we
could you know we could give it a try
why did that for probably go so bad what
was the problem with it did he have a
lot of background and education yeah we
had no diagrams there's this money to
this property to this day is because of
how well our rent to rent portfolio is
going that we are able to keep it but
buying a property cash we bought it cash
that makes no sense yeah you're not
invested that money somewhere else and
yeah you know made a profit how do you
systemize your rent to rent business and
how do you manage all of the tenants
you've got hmos you've got service
departments I think that's the part that
we have we are most proud of I think in
my opinion because for us to be able to
go from some 50 60 hours a week to a 15
hour week sort of like
um head down on on the property business
is really our systemization first of all
we used up all of the paperwork that
you've given us so all of the contracts
all of the things that you've provided
with us we've provided us with we made
sure that obviously they were good for
our business so we changed up things
that needed to be changed and things
like that but we already had a blueprint
of what we what would be needed and then
we just put it into
um process and procedure right so
anybody that comes in and help they're
able to just follow that process and for
us that made a lot of sense because we
can get someone working online that
doesn't have to be on site who is there
um he's going on site he does all of the
viewings all of the key Handover
maintenance he does it all yeah and it's
much cheaper to have him do it
um so we do that and we just have our
admin assistant which is someone that is
great
um in the Philippines oh no she's never
been to the UK yeah she is but she is a
wizard because we've got all of our
documents and all of our systems that's
already she knows all the steps so it's
easier for her to work from her yeah
yeah what as a as a teacher and an
educator yeah and I know we spoke a lot
about education and schools and things
like that what do you think um how's the
academy been in terms of Education the
academy is
is unvaluable yeah the type of
um help and support that we get first of
all from the moment you join you've got
your onboarding so already you've got
someone that explains you okay this is
the system that you go to if you need
this that and the other then you've got
all of the training that's online that
you can work you know with and just look
around and see if there is anything
um that you can start learning yourself
and starting implementing until you go
to the actual live event where you have
the the training and then you've got the
network as well with all of the groups
that we've got whether it's on Facebook
or Whatsapp or anything like that where
you can just pop in your question and
you've got 100 different people
answering about their own experiences so
it's always something that is so
accurate and precise because there is
nothing that we invented we didn't come
up with if I thought about it I can tell
you that a thousand other people have
thought about something or came across
something so just having that Network
that you can just bounce ideas of a
second to none there's nothing like it
I'm really glad to hear that and it
means a lot you know it's a real
compliment and the group that we've got
as well because it's not just a case of
the mentoring and the training it's also
the people I mean the network yeah but
you wouldn't have the network if we
didn't have the base which is you your
training and your delivery I've not seen
anything like it as an educator the way
you break down those Concepts you use
personal experience and you use some
actual legal legal legality and you use
all this accurate information with your
personal experience with others the way
you can pull out Knowledge from
everywhere to put up a training that
works across and it's not working
because you say it's working we are on
site with you when you're telling us
okay pick up your phone make that call
say this that and you know you are doing
it yeah in a way that there's no not one
person can stand up in front of you and
say your thing is not working because
you can just pull out your phone right
now and say okay cool find me a number
or how much is it okay no problem and
you make it happen live as we speak so
yeah now that's the thing as well
calling landlords and just doing it live
and then everyone's like okay because I
think the only way
um to learn something properly is to do
it and that's what on the training
programs it's not just it's not just
education it's also doing you know so
but you guys have just like implemented
so well and of course nobody can make
anybody else successful like I'll do my
best as a trainer I literally will be
like pushing people motivating teaching
inspiring holding people to work out but
you know ultimately everybody is where
they're at because of the work that they
put in and you know the fact that you
guys have got 14 rent to rent now it's
more completely insane where do you go
from here though what's like the plan
now moving forward are you just going to
keep getting rent to rent or are you
going to move into development or what's
the plan we want to move into
development and uh also help others like
us that are not very you know Financial
free and you know help out of the
knowledge that we have that's good it's
hard because it's really something
that's coming that's not natural to us
you know to be out there I mean we are
very quiet in the academy just picking
up peekaboo's brains and giving up
knowledge where we can but it's just
speaking with your mentors and all of
them the people that are around the
academy it would be selfish of us not to
share in some capacity so yeah because I
had to drag you on winners on a
Wednesday I was like 14 properties you
have to go on the show and you're I'm
not sure yeah you know it's it's a
confidence thing yeah what was it that
made you agree to come on and talk and
share today I'm just thinking about all
the things that we're doing that we can
Inspire other people out there that want
to do better and I want to obviously
take it further in property and yeah I
think one of the things that you were
telling me is that remember us you know
just remember us
because I was I was really hesitant but
he was like remember us that's remember
how we were you know some other people
may be in the same position coming from
the similar background yeah with first
generation in this country so
you know we we we feel the
um the struggle that people may have we
didn't come in this country with You
Know Rich parents or anything that you
can relate on that So eventually if we
can help someone like us you know that
wants to make it don't really know how
property doesn't have to be
your dream as a little girl it wasn't
mine but it's the vehicle that we're
taking to get to our Dream what's the
dream then
um
for us I think the dream would be well
first to be able to financially support
all of our families back home we
definitely want to be able to do that we
want to be able to retire our parents
fully
so that's like the short term dream but
then in the future as an educator you
know I have preschool so I do want to
bring those back home as well the
concept of early eight years education
is very foreign in our part of Africa
there is not a lot of emphasis on
earliest education but a lot of time the
issue that we will find with
um young adults came from childhood and
early childhood so we want to bring that
concept a little bit more into
the population and we want to be able to
help those with
issues like mental health and learning
disabilities these are complex issues
that are not spoken about very well or
very often in our part of the world so
we do want to kind of bring our
expertise and bring whatever we can but
whatever means to try and make someone
else's life a little bit easier that's
amazing and where is your part of Africa
mine is Ivory Coast mine is Congo
incredible and you know you you know
we're doing a lot of stuff out in Uganda
and education just yesterday I was
speaking at school and um I think that's
one of the reasons why we resonate you
know so well and I've got on really well
because of you know your hearts what
would be your final words of advice to
somebody watching this that really wants
to get into property but maybe you know
doesn't have the direction or is lacking
the financial education but they want to
get started what would you say would be
your best piece of advice how to say
education again yeah educate yourself
and get the right training yeah it's
very very important yeah I would say
probably never give up there's gonna be
so many rejections on the way yeah if
you have a dream and you believe that
for us is we believe that God has put
something in US yeah and this is
something that is very close to your out
there is no one on this Earth that can
take it away from you but you so just
keep on going do not give up persevere
and eventually you'll pay that's amazing
well thank you guys I appreciate you
coming to my house and sharing and uh
well done again on all your success
[Music]